what if we lost all our coral reefs
overnight ocean diving would become less
impressive that's for sure but what
about the marine ecosystems they sustain
how many sea animals would face
extinction could the corals rebuild
themselves from scratch how would this
massive die-off affect humanity this is
what if and here's what would happen if
all the coral reefs disappeared corals
are not rocks
they're huge colonies of a distant
relative of the jellyfish coral polyps
and like all living things they die the
warmer our oceans get the faster coral
reefs die out it only takes a water
temperature spike of one degree above
average to upset corals and make them
turn white this process is called
bleaching it makes corals more
vulnerable to hot temperatures and
causes their death if the water doesn't
cool down climate change has already
killed half of the Great Barrier Reef's
coral in just the last two years it's
only a matter of time until the last
coral vanishes from the oceans but what
if an abrupt heat wave destroyed all the
reefs overnight coral reefs take up just
1% of the world's marine environment so
no big deal right wrong just that 1% is
enough to sustain a quarter of all
marine animals in the ocean 2 million
species live in on and around the reefs
for them corals have been providing food
and shelter for 50 million years the day
the reefs disappeared marine
biodiversity would suffer huge losses
the ocean bottom would be taken over by
forests of seaweed
maybe it's time to give jellyfish soup a
try since there would be plenty of them
in the ocean but for many unique species
of fish in the ocean corals are their
only safe habitat a lot of them would be
lost for good
same goes for sea turtles since coral
are filter feeders that clean the water
remaining species including dolphins
would be left to survive in very murky
waters they might soon disappear as well
since when the corals disappear there
would be very little fish for them to
feed on but what about us would humans
on land be affected too absolutely
since reefs support fish they also
support the fisheries feeding and giving
jobs to 500 million people in tropical
countries like Indonesia Malaysia and
the Philippines of course the local
tourism industry should crash no one
wants to dive into a forest of seaweed
with no corals left coastal countries
would lose 375 billion dollars of annual
income coastlines would no longer be
protected from flooding and extreme
storms coral provides a natural
breakwater and a buffer against erosion
without it
water would push local residents out of
their homes as the oceans spread out the
residents of these
we populated islands that have nowhere
to go the countries might vanish from
the planet together with the reefs
without seafood will it be increased
pressure on farms to make up for the
shortfall in protein this might turn
into a global food crisis it's hard to
predict what else the disruption to the
food chain and biodiversity of the
oceans would lead to sure enough it
wouldn't be pretty the truth is this
hypothetical scenario is getting very
real the corals of Great Barrier Reef
are bleaching quickly and are unlikely
to recover can humans help their
survival well we aren't able to regrow
500 year old corals in just 50 years but
we can at least try to pollute our air
and oceans less that way the coral reefs
might be around to give enjoyment of
life to future generations of fish and
humans the next time you're looking for
a place to go on vacation
think about the impact you're making and
try to support local communities that
protect the oceans and ecosystems they
depend on and if you go diving or
snorkeling don't stand on the corals
always marvel at their incredible beauty
from a distance
[Music]